Shure:  牛逼
Shure: Awesome.
Jake: 过弯了吗哥
Jake: Did you make the turn, bro?
Shure:  过了
Shure: I did.
Jake: 过了
Jake: You did.
Shure:  换一个换一个吧
Shure: Let's switch, let's switch.
Jake: 可以可以行行
Jake: Alright, alright.
Jake:你要玩吗
Jake: Do you want to play?
Tasha:  我没有带手套哎
Tasha: I didn't bring gloves.
Shure:  最后再来4个
Shure: Four more for the last round.
Shure:  我再找找
Shure: I'll find some more.
Shure:  昨天我重新上传了个发票你可以
Shure: Yesterday, I re-uploaded an invoice, you can...
Shure:  昨天我重新上传了一个发票就是
Shure: Yesterday, I re-uploaded an invoice, it's...
Shure:  这个应该就是昨天
Shure: This should be from yesterday.
Shure:  没这个应该就是昨天那首
Shure: No, this should be from the song we talked about yesterday.
Shure:  就是昨天说发票错了的那首
Shure: It's the one with the wrong invoice from yesterday.
Shure:  这个的话哎呀
Shure: This one, well...
Shure:  这个你就
Shure: This one, you just...
Shure:  好的哥
Shure: Alright, bro.
Shure:  那你看
Shure: Look at this.
Shure:  我们刚
Shure: We just...
Shure:  我刚丢死人了
Shure: I just embarrassed myself so bad.
Shure:  我跟你讲那个我们去电玩城
Shure: I'm telling you, we went to the arcade.
Shure:  然后有那个架子鼓机吗
Shure: And they had this drum machine.
Shure:  结果打第一个我挑了一个最难的
Shure: So, I picked the hardest level first.
Shure:  然后没过
Shure: And I failed.
Shure:  死了game over了我靠
Shure: Game over, I'm like, oh man...
Shure:  飙一下吗
Shure: Wanna race?
Shure:  飙车吗
Shure: Wanna race cars?
Katrina: 飙车你有多少币
Katrina: How many coins do you have for the race?
Shure:  你还有币吗
Shure: Do you still have coins?
Shure:  我正好4个应该
Shure: I think I have exactly 4.
Katrina: 4个能够飙吗
Katrina: Is 4 enough for a race?
Shure:  一个人飙吗
Shure: Just one person racing?
Shure:  那是我要10个啊
Shure: Then I need 10 coins.
Katrina: 好像十个哎
Katrina: Seems like it's ten coins.
Katrina: 啊你去看看
Katrina: Ah, go check it out.
Shure:  不是4个吗
Shure: Isn't it 4 coins?
Katrina: 我想着四五块差不多了是吧
Katrina: I thought it was around four or five.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure:  我靠我在家老玩那个
Shure: Man, I play that all the time at home.
Shure:  对啊就是那边那个
Shure: Yeah, it's the one over there.
Shure:  那个湾岸是吧
Shure: The Wangan, right?
Shure:  哇啊
Shure: Whoa, ah.
Shure:  这是哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: This is... hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈你你这个不亮了
Jake: Hahaha, your thing isn't lighting up.
Jake: 你这你这没电了吗
Jake: Is it out of battery?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Tasha: 他的心可能碎了
Tasha: His heart might be broken.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  还有还有多少个
Shure: How many are left?
Jake: 快没了
Jake: Almost gone.
Shure:  它要五五个
Shure: It needs five coins.
Shure:  飙一次有10个吗
Shure: Does it take 10 coins to race once?
Shure:  有有人跟我标一下吗
Shure: Anyone want to race with me?
Jake: 飙什么呀
Jake: Race what?
Shure:  飙一下这个
Shure: Race this.
Jake: 这个是多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Shure:  五个一次
Shure: Five each time.
Jake: 这么多啊
Jake: That much?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Yeah.
Jake: 感觉凑这边还有两个
Jake: Feels like there are two more over here.
Jake: 谁要跟他飙
Jake: Who wants to race with him?
Shure:  这只有5个
Shure: There are only 5.
Shure:  不够了
Shure: Not enough.
Jake: 五个现在总共凑不出来了
Jake: We can't even gather five now.
Katrina: 玩这小机子呢
Katrina: Playing this little machine.
Shure:  哈哈哈币一次
Shure: Hahaha, one coin each time.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina: 这好玩
Katrina: This is fun.
Shure:  哎我靠
Shure: Oh, damn.
Shure:  应该有2P那种
Shure: Should have 2P type.
Katrina: 哎这是4币
Katrina: Oh, this is 4 coins.
Shure:  但是我们只有7个
Shure: But we only have 7.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Shure:  那边呢
Shure: What about over there?
Shure:  哦那边3币
Shure: Oh, 3 coins over there.
Shure:  来来那个来那个
Shure: Come on, let's go for that one.
Shure:  那个给我飙一下
Shure: Let's race with that one.
Shure:  来
Shure: Come on.
Shure:  come on
Katrina: 给我一个币
Katrina: Give me a coin.
Shure: 给你一个
Shure: Here, take one.
Katrina: 3个是吧哦
Katrina: 3 coins, right? Oh.
Jake: 一群赛博人进达赛博区域
Jake: A group of cyborgs entering the cyber zone.
Katrina: 这怎么玩啊
Katrina: How do you play this?
Katrina: 我看看就左右开车会开
Katrina: Let me see, just drive left and right?
Shure:  车会开吧
Shure: Can you drive?
Shure:   那就一样了
Shure: Then it's the same.
Jake: 会开车吗
Jake: Can you drive?
Katrina: 会开哈哈
Katrina: I can drive, haha.
Jake: 怎么还有怎么在拍我啊
Jake: Why are you still filming me?
Jake: 啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Katrina: 请把获取的二维码放来
Katrina: Please display the QR code you obtained.
Shure:  没事不用管
Shure: It's fine, ignore it.
Jake: 为什么都在拍我呢
Jake: Why is everyone filming me?
Jake: 这个地方
Jake: This place.
Katrina: 不知道啊
Katrina: I don't know.
Shure:  直接按开始就好
Shure: Just press start directly.
Jake: 这这相机是
Jake: This camera is...
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 你得到这注册一下还是这个意思是吧
Jake: You need to register this, right?
Shure:  对但是可以不注册
Shure: Yeah, but you can skip the registration.
Jake: 是上车之前拍个照
Jake: Take a picture before you get in the car.
Jake: 然后再上车
Jake: Then get in.
Jake: 考驾照啊
Jake: For the driving test?
Shure:  啊对
Shure: Yeah, right.
Katrina: 这为啥一直要那个
Katrina: Why do we always need that?
Shure:  你直接开始跳过对
Shure: Just start and skip it.
Jake: 就开始开始呗开始
Jake: Just start, just start.
Katrina: 向上拉动扣子
Katrina: Pull up the button.
Shure:  当然是开我的AE86了
Shure: Of course, I'll drive my AE86.
Shure:  然后选那个店内对战
Shure: Then choose the in-store battle.
Katrina: 自动挡哈哈
Katrina: Automatic, haha.
Shure:  啊选那个店内对战
Shure: Yeah, choose the in-store battle.
Katrina: 哪啊
Katrina: Where?
Shure:  往往往右往右往右对对
Shure: Go right, right, right. Yes.
Katrina: 这个
Katrina: This one?
Shure:  然后开始
Shure: Then start.
Shure:  拉车队
Shure: Form a team.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 是不是只要踩油门跟刹车
Katrina: Just need to step on the gas and brake?
Shure:  对对
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 对这不用弄是不是
Katrina: I don't need to do anything else, right?
Jake: 币用光了吗
Jake: Are the tokens used up?
Jake: 还是还有
Jake: Or are there more?
Shure:  还有最后一个
Shure: There's one left.
Katrina: 还有一个
Katrina: One left.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Shure:  你可以试试推beat
Shure: You can try pushing beat.
Shure:  为什么他这这么慢啊好
Shure: Why is it so slow? Okay.
Katrina: 我现在搞不清哪个是刹车
Katrina: I can't tell which is the brake.
Katrina: 哪个是油门啊
Katrina: Which is the gas?
Katrina: 啊哈哈
Katrina: Ah, haha.
Katrina: 哇这被超了
Katrina: Wow, I got overtaken.
Katrina: 撞了你哈哈哈哈
Katrina: I crashed into you, hahaha.
Shure:  弯道快才是真的快
Shure: Only fast in the turns is truly fast.
Shure:  洒洒水了
Shure: Just a piece of cake.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow
Shure:  手机掉了
Shure: Dropped my phone.
Shure:  win
Shure: Win
Lucia:  还有谁要玩的吗
Lucia: Anyone else wants to play?
Katrina: 只能玩一个人
Katrina: Only one person can play.
Shure:  还有几个币子
Shure: How many tokens do we have left?
Lucia:  给我这还有我还可以再再开个车
Lucia: I have some, I can start another game.
Lucia:  所以如果有人要玩的话可以再玩一局
Lucia: So if anyone wants to play, we can go another round.
Shure:  他可以再这个
Shure: He can play again.
Shure:  因为他赢了
Shure: Because he won.
Shure:  他是不需要再投币子的
Shure: He doesn't need to insert another token.
Shure:  所以如果想玩的话可以再来一次
Shure: So if someone wants to play, they can go again.
Shure:  杨老板要试试吗
Shure: Jake, do you want to try?
Jake: 再来一局
Jake: Another round.
Lucia:  那我跟你再来一局哈哈哈
Lucia: Then I'll go another round with you, hahaha.
Katrina: 那你俩玩
Katrina: You two play then.
Lucia:  所以啥意思
Lucia: So what does that mean?
Lucia:  是你那边不用投是吧
Lucia: You don't need to insert a token, right?
Shure:  对应该这边不用投
Shure: Right, I shouldn't need to insert one here.
Jake: 这你还可以续一局是吧
Jake: So you can continue another round, right?
Shure:  对我可以续一局
Shure: Yes, I can continue.
Jake: 哦你无论如何都有一局
Jake: Oh, so you always have another round no matter what.
Lucia:  嗯然后呢
Lucia: Hmm, and then?
Shure:  啊不行不行不行
Shure: Ah, no no no.
Lucia:  那你投呗
Lucia: Then just insert it.
Lucia:  我因为我我已经投了咱俩要一块吗
Lucia: Because I already inserted it, are we playing together?
Shure:  你已经投了3个BG
Shure: You've already inserted 3 BGs.
Lucia:  啊我这边投过了
Lucia: Ah, I've already inserted it here.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK
Lucia:  然后我按开始吗
Lucia: Then do I press start?
Shure:  对你按开始
Shure: Yes, you press start.
Jake: 现在还剩几个呀不剩了
Jake: How many are left now? None left?
Shure:  正好对
Shure: Exactly, yes.
Shure:  正好不剩
Shure: Exactly none left.
Shure:  你们你们
Shure: You guys, you guys...
Shure:  谁要再来一局
Shure: Who wants to go another round?
Shure:  来来试一试
Shure: Come on, give it a try.
Shure:  还有人要来一局吗
Shure: Anyone else wants to go another round?
Shure:  耶
Shure: Yay
Shure:  完了
Shure: It's over.
Shure:  你来
Shure: You go.
Katrina: 你不玩吗不玩
Katrina: Aren't you playing? Not playing?
Shure:  我不玩了先
Shure: I'm not playing for now.
Lucia:  然后呢我现在我现在干嘛
Lucia: So, what should I do now?
Lucia:  他为啥要让我用微信
Lucia: Why does he want me to use WeChat?
Lucia:  开始
Lucia: Start.
Katrina: 不用微信
Katrina: No need for WeChat.
Shure:  哎别管
Shure: Hey, don't worry about it.
Katrina: 直接star star就行
Katrina: Just hit start, start is fine.
Shure:  坐我这边是手动
Shure: Sitting here is manual.
Katrina: 手动挡吗
Katrina: Manual transmission?
Katrina: 什么手动挡啊
Katrina: What manual transmission?
Shure:  手动挡是的
Shure: It's manual, yes.
Katrina: 手动挡我都忘记怎么开了
Katrina: I forgot how to drive manual.
Shure: 选选吧
Shure: Pick one.
Lucia:  没事难的就行了不重要
Lucia: It's fine, just choose a difficult one, it doesn't matter.
Shure:  这辆怎么样
Shure: How about this one?
Lucia:  可以就这样是吧
Lucia: Sure, this one, right?
Shure:  你
Shure: You.
Shure:  默认
Shure: Default.
Shure:  先放到一档
Shure: Put it in first gear first.
Shure:  啊不不不
Shure: Ah, no, no, no.
Shure:  点这个啊
Shure: Press this one.
Shure:  完了完了点错了
Shure: Oh no, oh no, pressed the wrong one.
Lucia:  咋这样吗
Lucia: Is it like this?
Shure:  啊你我靠
Shure: Ah, you, oh man.
Shure:  能返回吗
Shure: Can we go back?
Shure:  完了返回不了了
Shure: Oh no, we can't go back.
Shure:  完了他返回不了了
Shure: It's over, we can't go back.
Shure:  好吧那只能
Shure: Alright, then we can only...
Shure:  只能自己玩了
Shure: Only play by ourselves now.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Oh man.
Shure:  你点错了刚刚
Shure: You pressed the wrong one earlier.
Katrina: 不是已经搞到6了吗
Katrina: Didn't we get to 6 already?
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Shure:  看到弯路
Shure: See the bend.
Shure:  你前转一点就会比他快
Shure: If you turn a bit ahead, you'll be faster.
Shure:  然后你并到内线的道上
Shure: Then merge into the inside lane.
Shure:  就会比他快一些
Shure: You'll be a bit faster.
Shure:  杨老板去干嘛了
Shure: Where did Jake go?
Shure:  什么叫死状
Shure: What do you mean by 'death pose'?
Katrina: 爽了
Katrina: Feels good.
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Lucia:  我我我不知道
Lucia: I-I-I don't know.
Jake: 是吧是啊
Jake: Right, yeah.
Lucia:  是我就随便按一下
Lucia: So I just pressed it randomly.
Jake: 决决定吧
Jake: Make a decision.
Shure:  对这没没有用了
Shure: Yeah, this is useless.
Shure:  因为他得续费的
Shure: Because it needs a renewal.
Shure:  走啊没了
Shure: Let's go, it's over.
Jake: 哎啊没了
Jake: Yeah, it's over.
Shure:  走啊走
Shure: Let's go, go.
Jake: 收获满满
Jake: We gained a lot.
Katrina: 哈哈床上有东西装饰
Katrina: Haha, there's something on the bed for decoration.
Shure:  就他抓到了是吗
Shure: Did he catch it?
Jake: 对还好还好有个东西证明我们来过
Jake: Yes, fortunately, there's something to prove we were here.
Jake: 不然这一段可能就撵不上
Jake: Otherwise, we might not catch up with this part.
其他人：可以做一下装饰吗
Others: Can we use it as decoration?
Jake: 对对对然后问这哪来的对
Jake: Yes, yes, then ask where it came from.
Lucia:  还有谁要抓娃娃吗
Lucia: Does anyone else want to grab dolls?
Lucia:  我刚拿了大概15个的样子还有仨
Lucia: I just grabbed about 15, and there are three more.
Shure:  还有仨
Shure: Three more.
Lucia:  对我刚对
Lucia: Yes, I just, yes.
Jake: 还有啊
Jake: More?
Lucia:  我刚拿了大概15个的样子
Lucia: I just grabbed about 15.
Lucia:  居然还有仨
Lucia: There are still three more.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 还有还有三个
Jake: There are still three more.
Shure:  我们把币子推出来
Shure: Let's push the coins out.
Shure:  我们我们用钱生钱
Shure: Let's use money to make money.
Shure:  好吧我们把
Shure: Alright, let's...
Lucia:  这能推下来吗
Lucia: Can this be pushed down?
Shure:  我看看
Shure: Let me see.
Jake: 呃那边还有一个保龄球一块钱
Jake: Uh, there's a bowling pin over there, one coin.
Shure:  什么保联型
Shure: What bowling pin?
Jake: 玩了很久
Jake: Played for a long time.
Jake: 因为前面有个人投了两个币
Jake: Because someone put in two coins earlier.
Jake: 还剩一个就可以玩
Jake: There's one left, and you can play.
Lucia:  啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake: 然后我们在钱生钱这这这这这这
Jake: And then we can make money out of this this this this...
Jake: 我们就可以搜一下
Jake: We can just search it up.
Jake: 看有没有3-2-3的对3-4的哈哈哈
Jake: See if there's a 3-2-3 against a 3-4, hahaha.
Shure:   啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  哈哈在地下捡烟头抽的这种是吧
Shure: Haha, like picking up cigarette butts from the ground to smoke, right?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Jake: 2/3
Jake: 2/3.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  还真有
Shure: There really is.
Jake: 来个2/3 对
Jake: Let's go with 2/3, right.
Lucia:  大家大家
Lucia: Everyone, everyone.
Lucia:  大家决定
Lucia: Everyone decide.
Shure:  这个吗这只只需要投一个就可以
Shure: This one, right? We just need to vote one.
Jake: 2-32-3呢因为有个神仙有个菩萨
Jake: 2-3, 2-3 because there's a god, a bodhisattva.
Lucia:  这么神奇
Lucia: That's amazing.
Shure:  因为有有一个人投了两个
Shure: Because someone voted twice.
Lucia:  哦那投投投
Lucia: Oh then vote, vote, vote.
Jake: 有个菩萨之前
Jake: There was a bodhisattva before.
Tasha:  这个刚刚是也投了俩
Tasha: This one just voted twice too.
Shure:  这怎么怎么玩
Shure: How do we play this?
Jake: 对这个也是2/3
Jake: Yeah, this one is also 2/3.
Jake: 这也是2/3
Jake: This is also 2/3.
Lucia:  哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia:  神奇
Lucia: Amazing.
Lucia:  谁先来
Lucia: Who goes first?
Shure:  我试试
Shure: I'll try.
Jake: 来了
Jake: Here we go.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Lucia:  哇居然是现实和屏幕结合
Lucia: Wow, it's combining reality and the screen.
Jake: 哈哈哈是耶
Jake: Hahaha, it is.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Lucia:  哇厉害
Lucia: Wow, impressive.
Shure:  strike全雷打懂吗
Shure: Strike, a home run, you know?
Jake: 来你还有一个
Jake: Come on, you have one more.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Shure:  练过的
Shure: I've practiced.
Jake: 练我
Jake: Practice me.
Jake: 可以好下去吧
Jake: Alright, let's go down.
Shure: 然后呢
Shure: And then?
Jake: 哈哈哈换下一个
Jake: Hahaha, next one!
Shure:  下一位
Shure: Next person.
Jake: 要拿要帮你拿东西吗
Jake: Do you need help carrying anything?
Jake: 来
Jake: Come here.
Jake: 对就越中间越好
Jake: Yes, the more in the center, the better.
Shure:  就这样然后趴下去
Shure: Just like this, then lie down.
Jake: 那还你还有一次机会
Jake: You still have one more chance.
Shure:  split
Shure: Split.
Jake: 你可以往左边打一打
Jake: You can hit it a bit to the left.
Tasha:  球
Tasha: Ball.
Jake: 球来了
Jake: The ball is coming.
Lucia:  哦OK
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Tasha:  补中
Tasha: Hit the mark.
Jake: 哈哈哈好
Jake: Hahaha, good.
Jake: 来吧
Jake: Come on.
Lucia:  谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Jake: 稳稳健
Jake: Steady, steady.
Jake: 极其稳健
Jake: Very steady.
Jake: 也有个火鸡
Jake: There's a turkey.
其他人：哇
Others: Wow.
Shure:  strike
Shure: Strike.
Jake: 上火鸡就一次
Jake: One turkey at a time.
Jake: 全砸中就有个火鸡
Jake: A full strike gets you a turkey.
Jake: 哈哈没关系这左边右边都没有差别
Jake: Haha, it's okay, it doesn't matter left or right.
Shure:  82
Shure: 82.
Tasha:  啊我比你厉害哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah, I'm better than you, hahaha.
Jake: 比你还多比你还多比你还多
Jake: More than you, more than you, more than you.
Jake: 越歪分越高你知道不
Jake: The more off-center, the higher the score, you know?
Shure:  来下一位
Shure: Next person.
Jake: 来来来来来来
Jake: Come on, come on, come on.
Katrina: 我来吗
Katrina: Is it my turn?
Katrina: 咿呀
Katrina: Oh my.
Shure:  你这好随意啊
Shure: You're so casual.
Jake: 哈哈手滑了
Jake: Haha, slipped my hand.
Jake: 还有还有还有
Jake: More, more, more.
Shure:  现实中你这就是Ghetto
Shure: In real life, that's just ghetto. 社会问题
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 是一个很随便的人
Katrina: I'm a very casual person.
Katrina: 还有吗球来了
Katrina: Is there more? The ball is coming.
Shure:  助跑两步球来了球来了
Shure: Take two steps and here comes the ball, here comes the ball.
Jake: 球球来了
Jake: The ball is coming.
Jake: 球已经来了
Jake: The ball is already here.
Katrina: 哦哦已经来了
Katrina: Oh, it's already here.
Shure:  送出去给他
Shure: Pass it to him.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  可以
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 紫藤来
Jake: Violet, come on.
Katrina: 补中
Katrina: Cover.
Jake: 紫藤来
Jake: Violet, come on.
Shure:  紫藤
Shure: Violet.
其他人：我来我来我来
Others: I'll do it, I'll do it.
Lucia:  哎为什么会拿这把枪
Lucia: Hey, why are you using this gun?
Jake: 哎怎么这么多
Jake: Hey, why so many?
Lucia:  放着吧啊行
Lucia: Just leave it here, okay?
Tasha:  快
Tasha: Quick.
Shure:  完了要split了
Shure: It's over, we're gonna split.
Shure:  好全中
Shure: Alright, all hit.
Lucia:  哇哦
Lucia: Wow.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Jake: 还有是吧
Jake: Is there more?
Jake: 还有可心还有吧
Jake: Is there more, Kexin?
Jake: 还有还有还有可心呢
Katrina: 几个币啊
Katrina: How many coins?
Katrina: 玩这么久可以
Katrina: Playing for so long, okay.
Jake: 呵一个一个一个
Jake: Haha, one by one.
Jake: 你这个带钻的你知道吧
Jake: You know this one has diamonds, right?
Lucia:  怎么回事啊哈哈哈
Lucia: What's going on? Hahaha.
Jake: 来把他干掉
Jake: Come on, take him down.
Shure: 准吗
Shure: Is it accurate?
Lucia:  那我就再把这一个打中呗
Lucia: Then I'll hit this one again.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 稳稳健
Jake: Steady.
Katrina: 哇感觉可以
Katrina: Wow, it feels good.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yay.
Lucia:  耶
Lucia: Yay.
Lucia:  他应该会还有一局
Lucia: He should have one more round.
Lucia:  我怎么感觉
Lucia: I feel like...
Tasha:  没有了啊
Tasha: No more, huh?
Jake: 没了没了就结束了
Jake: No more, it's over.
Jake: 好走吧
Jake: Okay, let's go.
Katrina: 我去买东西
Katrina: I'm going to buy something.
Jake: 还有两个币
Jake: There are still two coins.
Jake: 两个币就钱生钱
Jake: With two coins, money makes money.
Jake: 对对对对钱生钱
Jake: Yes, yes, money makes money.
Shure:  对对对钱生钱来
Shure: Yes, yes, money makes money. Come on.
Shure:  我还有这个的卡呢我还有这个的卡
Shure: I still have this card, I still have this card.
Shure:  然后里面有一匹
Shure: And it has one horse inside.
Shure:  有一辆700匹的
Shure: A car with 700 horsepower.
Shure:  一个奥迪
Shure: An Audi.
Lucia:  要推币吗
Lucia: Do you want to push the coin?
Shure:  生吧
Shure: Sure.
Lucia:  推一个吧
Lucia: Push one.
Lucia:  找一个看哪个好推
Lucia: Find one that's easy to push.
Shure:  啊这好像人占着呢
Lucia:  这个这个卡住了这没开
Lucia: This one is stuck, it's not open.
Lucia:  看别的吧
Lucia: Let's check another one.
Katrina: 这有啥技巧吗
Katrina: Is there any technique to this?
Shure:  这这有人有人有人都
Shure: There, there, someone, someone, someone...
Lucia:  这个好像也没开吧
Lucia: This one doesn't seem to be open either, right?
Shure:  教你们技巧
Shure: I'll teach you the technique.
Shure:  他他他伸进去
Shure: He, he, he puts it in.
Shure:  伸进去的时候对
Shure: When he puts it in, yeah.
Tasha:  伸进去时再放
Tasha: Put it in and then release.
Shure:  32
Shure: 32.
Tasha:  放呀
Tasha: Release it.
Tasha:  放在哪了
Tasha: Where did you put it?
Lucia:  哦你按他才会释放好像
Lucia: Oh, you have to press it for it to release, it seems.
Tasha:  好石沉大海
Tasha: It's like dropping into the ocean.
Shure:  再来一个我们
Shure: Let's try another one.
Jake: 这是蝴蝶效应
Jake: This is the butterfly effect.
Lucia:  就是是怎么放进去
Lucia: How do you put it in?
Jake: 在前1秒钟
Jake: In the first second.
Shure:  对对
Shure: Yes, yes.
Lucia:  然后按一下他才会掉下来
Lucia: Then press it to make it fall.
Lucia:  按微微按哈哈
Lucia: Press it gently, haha.
Shure:  okay放
Shure: Okay, release.
Katrina: 啊就这么玩吗
Katrina: Ah, is this how you play it?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:  好像叠住了哈哈
Lucia: It seems to be stuck, haha.
Shure:  完了
Shure: It's over.
Jake: 走吧哈哈哈
Jake: Let's go, hahaha.
Katrina: 就这么玩的吗
Katrina: Are we playing like this?
Katrina: 就掉下去
Katrina: Just falling down like this.
Jake: 走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Lucia:  我记得小时候
Lucia: I remember when I was little.
Lucia:  这个推币机特别容易掉币
Lucia: This coin pusher used to drop coins so easily.
Lucia:  现在好像都把它改造的越来越不容易
Lucia: But now it seems like they've modified it to be harder.
Lucia:  赢了
Lucia: I won.
Shure:  看人家酷酷酷酷酷
Shure: Look at them, so cool, cool, cool.
其他人：外面好 好清爽啊
Others: It's so refreshing outside.
Lucia:  嗯哈里面好吵
Lucia: Yeah, it's so noisy inside.
Shure:  哎杨老板呢
Shure: Hey, where's Jake?
Shure:  盒马盒马
Shure: Hema, Hema.
Shure:  俺们要盒马
Shure: We need Hema.
Shure:  miniso
Shure: Miniso.
Katrina: 我去一趟好特卖我要买东西
Katrina: I'm going to Hotmax, I need to buy something.
其他人：我也去
Others: I'm coming too.
Shure:  out max
Shure: Out max.
Shure:  我这是活活着装好吧
Shure: I'm just pretending to be alive, okay?
Shure:  这边会有很特价的东西是吗
Shure: Will there be special deals here?
Katrina: 也倒不是说很特别
Katrina: Not particularly special.
Katrina: 就是它的保质期可能没那么长
Katrina: It's just that the shelf life might not be very long.
Katrina: 但是很适合你
Katrina: But it's perfect for you.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Katrina: 马上要用
Katrina: You need to use it soon.
Shure:  今晚要写毕设
Shure: I need to write my thesis tonight.
Katrina: 今晚什么
Katrina: Write what tonight?
Shure:  要写毕设
Shure: I need to write my thesis.
Katrina: 我也要写毕设
Katrina: I need to write mine too.
Shure:  嗯找自习室去吧哈哈哈
Shure: Let's go find a study room, hahaha.
Katrina: 反正是
Katrina: Anyway...
Katrina: 我问一下哈
Katrina: Let me ask.
Katrina: 你好有那种压缩的洗脸巾吗
Katrina: Excuse me, do you have those compressed face towels?
其他人：没有
Others: No.
Katrina: 那只能买大包了
Katrina: Then I'll have to buy the big pack.
Katrina: 买大包在一起用算了
Katrina: Buy the big pack and just use it together.
Shure:  拿那个厨房用纸
Shure: Use kitchen paper towels.
Katrina: 厨房用纸洗脸
Katrina: Use kitchen paper towels to wash your face?
Katrina: 付款
Katrina: Pay.
Tasha:  哦果然他们已经开始买了
Tasha: Oh, it looks like they have already started buying.
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure:  这这是一个
Shure: This is a...
Jake: 啥呀这都是
Jake: What is all this?
Shure:  超级特价超市
Shure: Super discount supermarket.
Jake: 噢噢噢
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Shure:  杨老板逛过吗
Shure: Jake, have you ever been here?
Jake: 没有那
Jake: No, I haven't.
Shure:  新加坡有有
Shure: They have these in Singapore too.
Shure:  有这种的吗
Shure: Do they have these kinds of stores?
Jake: 3块3的牙刷好有
Jake: They have 3 yuan toothbrushes, sure.
Jake: 好像没有一元
Jake: But I don't think they have 1 yuan items.
Jake: 问到就是那种什么刀了
Jake: If you ask, it's like, what kind of knife do you want?
其他人：要个袋吗
Others: Do you need a bag?
Shure:  one dollar shop是吧对
Shure: It's like a one dollar shop, right?
Jake:  one dollar那些
Jake: Yeah, those one dollar items.
Jake: 都有什么比较优秀的便宜的东西呢
Jake: What kind of good and cheap stuff do they have?
Lucia:  不知道我也只逛过一次
Lucia: I don't know, I've only been here once.
Jake: 3块9的巴黎矿泉水早上
Jake: 3.9 yuan for Paris mineral water in the morning.
Shure:  挂面
Shure: Noodles.
Jake: 应该再整点这个对
Jake: Should get some of these, right.
Lucia:  哦这个这个
Lucia: Oh, this, this...
Lucia:  在这里卖的还挺便宜的嘛
Lucia: It's pretty cheap here.
Shure:  为什么啊
Shure: Why though?
Lucia:  这在国国内有地方卖老贵
Lucia: In some places in our country, it's super expensive.
Shure:  确实 12块5呢
Shure: Indeed, it's 12.5 yuan.
Jake: 卖老贵
Jake: Super expensive.
Jake: 哦真的呀 12块5
Jake: Oh really, 12.5 yuan?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Yeah.
Lucia:  嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure:  星巴克那玻璃那个更贵巴黎水
Shure: That glass bottle at Starbucks is even more expensive, Paris water.
Jake: 啊这个些酒是不是也很便宜
Jake: Ah, these wines are also very cheap, aren't they?
Shure:  啊确实
Shure: Yeah, indeed.
Jake: 整两瓶相比比较
Jake: Let's grab two bottles, it's a good deal.
Shure:  我靠这个香槟只要39块钱
Shure: Whoa, this champagne is only 39 yuan.
Shure:  这个气泡酒
Shure: This sparkling wine.
Jake: 心动吗
Jake: Tempted?
Katrina: 这real好便宜啊
Katrina: This is really cheap.
Lucia:  而且这是Moscato
Lucia: And it's Moscato.
Shure:  就比较有名的是吗
Shure: It's quite famous, right?
Katrina: cheap
Lucia:  对但是当
Lucia: Right, but when
Lucia:  当然也要看你
Lucia: Of course, it also depends on
Lucia:  就是本身葡萄的质量怎么样
Lucia: the quality of the grapes themselves.
Lucia:  但是就是莫斯卡托应该是产地
Lucia: But the Moscato, it should be about the origin
Lucia:  就这个地方应该不错了
Lucia: so this place should be good.
Shure:  不是有效 2033年
Shure: It's not valid until 2033.
Lucia:  没事酒酒酒
Lucia: No problem, wine, wine, wine.
Lucia:  好像没有什么特别特殊的
Lucia: It doesn't seem to be anything particularly special.
Shure:  蒋一蒋一撇
Shure: Check it out.
Jake: 选一品
Jake: Pick one.
Shure:  今天晚上蹦一下好吧
Shure: Let's pop one tonight, okay?
Jake: 我们好啊
Jake: We're good.
Katrina: 就是可以搞点real不
Katrina: Can we get something real?
Jake: 今晚能蹦吗
Jake: Can we pop one tonight?
Shure:  可以也可以蹦
Shure: Sure, we can pop one.
Shure:  因为冰箱里还有一瓶
Shure: Because there's still a bottle in the fridge.
Lucia:  冰箱还有一瓶
Lucia: There's still a bottle in the fridge.
Jake: 那今晚崩一个哦好
Jake: Then let's pop one tonight, alright.
Lucia:  我们那天买了一瓶起泡酒
Lucia: We bought a bottle of sparkling wine that day.
Shure:  今天晚上蹦一个
Shure: Let's pop one tonight.
Shure:  这个素材得给AI看一下吧
Shure: This material should be shown to AI.
Jake: 对 39块钱听个响挺好的
Jake: Yeah, 39 yuan for a pop is pretty good.
Shure:  来咱们39块钱今晚听个响
Shure: Come on, let's enjoy a 39 yuan pop tonight.
Jake: 对我我我买的那个10个USB的充电器
Jake: Yeah, I bought that 10-port USB charger.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Jake: 也3030多块钱一个
Jake: It was also around 30 yuan each.
Jake: 响也没有就是一点都都充不上
Jake: But it doesn't even charge properly.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake: 看起来挺牛逼
Jake: It looked pretty cool.
Alice:起泡酒吗
Alice: Sparkling wine?
Shure:  对就可以蹦听个响
Shure: Yeah, just for a pop.
Jake: 这好歹能听个响
Jake: At least we get a pop out of it.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia:  我跟我朋友第一回开起泡酒的时候
Lucia: The first time my friend and I opened sparkling wine,
Lucia:  我们俩打开
Lucia: we opened it
Lucia:  不知道接下来怎么处理
Lucia: and didn't know what to do next.
Lucia:  他就放在那
Lucia: So we just left it there.
Lucia:  就过一会他嘣哈哈哈
Lucia: After a while, it popped, hahaha.
Jake: 哦延时崩
Jake: Oh, delayed pop.
Alice:听个响
Alice: Listen to the sound
Jake: 延时听个响
Jake: Delayed sound
Shure:  还有什么想买的吗Minasa
Shure: Anything else you want to buy, Minasa?
Jake: 还有啥好东西
Jake: Any other good stuff?
Shure:  你知道黄桃黄桃罐头吗
Shure: Do you know about canned yellow peaches?
Jake: 我知道治感冒的
Jake: I know it's for curing colds
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Yep
Alice:哈哈哈啊
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina: 买点小零食当那个
Katrina: Buy some snacks for that
Lucia:  啊是真的可以治感冒吗
Lucia: Oh, can it really cure colds?
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes
Jake: 是吗
Jake: Really?
Shure:  真的
Shure: Really
Katrina: 可以买什么
Katrina: What can we buy?
Shure:  在东北可以
Shure: In the northeast, it works
Shure:  在别的地就不灵了
Shure: Elsewhere, not so much
Shure:  这个东西
Shure: This thing
Lucia:  有这样的吗
Lucia: Is that so?
Jake: 就跟拜佛似的也治感冒
Jake: It's like praying to Buddha for a cure too
Shure:  这是
Shure: This is
Alice:黄桃罐头
Alice: Canned yellow peaches
Shure:  就是这个东西
Shure: This is it
Jake: 拜菩萨也治感冒对
Jake: Praying to Bodhisattva cures colds too
Shure:  非非常的违心
Shure: Very superstitious
Alice:拜妈祖
Alice: Praying to Mazu
Alice:福建的管用
Alice: It works in Fujian
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes
Katrina: 想买一包咪咪吃
Katrina: I want to buy a bag of snacks
Katrina: 就当那个
Katrina: Just for that
Katrina: 等早饭外卖
Katrina: While waiting for breakfast delivery
Katrina: 的垫垫肚子那个
Katrina: To fill the stomach a bit
Jake: 啊行行行
Jake: Okay, okay
Shure:  小零食可以
Shure: Snacks are fine
Shure:  这不是野餐零食吗哈哈
Shure: Aren't these picnic snacks? Haha
Katrina: 拿呗
Katrina: Take it then
Shure:  一块钱
Shure: One dollar
Alice:什么玩意
Alice: What is this?
Tasha:  不在话下薄荷糖
Tasha: No problem, mint candy
Katrina: 一块钱
Katrina: One dollar
Tasha:  哦结你
Tasha: Oh, here you go
Tasha:  你结过账了是吧
Tasha: You've already paid, right?
Katrina: 我没有我买的是自己的东西
Katrina: No, I bought my own stuff.
Katrina: 他们还没结呢
Katrina: They haven't paid yet.
Shure:  这样我们我们都给杨老板换
Shure: So we'll all exchange with Jake.
Shure:  换算成新币
Shure: Convert to new currency.
Shure:  咱们都对
Shure: We'll all...
Alice:这样听起来就不心疼了哈哈
Alice: That way it won't hurt as much, haha.
Jake: 这个太离谱了吧 5毛新币
Jake: This is ridiculous, 50 cents in new currency.
Jake: 5毛钱的新币
Jake: 50 cents in new currency.
Jake: 什么东西
Jake: What's that?
Katrina: 五毛钱新加坡币
Katrina: 50 cents Singapore dollars.
Shure:  3块9就5毛钱是吗
Shure: 3.9 is just 50 cents, right?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake: 是6毛钱吧
Jake: It's 60 cents, right?
Jake: 是51:五点三吧现在得
Jake: It's 51:5.3 now, right?
Shure:  你就除以5减3
Shure: You just divide by 5 and subtract 3.
Shure:  你大概除以5
Shure: Roughly divide by 5.
Shure:  然后再减去摸个0就对了
Shure: Then subtract a random 0 and you're good.
Jake: 对给我报新币吧
Jake: Yeah, report in new currency.
Jake: 你这多少钱这
Jake: How much is this?
Shure:  在7新币也就
Shure: About 7 new currency.
Jake: 七新币的酒
Jake: Seven dollars for the wine.
Jake: 这听这这也听
Jake: This sounds...
Jake: 呵呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Shure:  听个响还能
Shure: Just for the sound.
Jake: 还来听个响
Jake: Just for the sound.
Katrina: 走OK了
Katrina: Let's go, okay.
Lucia:  好像也还行
Lucia: Seems alright.
Lucia:  奥迪和丽豆里面应该有不少这个价格
Lucia: There should be quite a few at this price in Aldi and Lidl.
Lucia:  你们那有奥迪和丽豆
Lucia: Do you have Aldi and Lidl there?
Katrina: 欧了欧了
Katrina: Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Jake: 我们不怎么买不太懂
Jake: We don't buy much, not very familiar.
Jake: 但是七新币听起来就很便宜
Jake: But seven new currency sounds really cheap.
Alice:这个牌子小啤酒
Alice: This brand of small beer.
Shure:  懂了懂了
Shure: Got it, got it.
Shure:  这这多少
Shure: How much is this?
Shure:  这不到1新币
Shure: Less than 1 new currency.
Shure:  这这一袋那什么
Shure: This bag...
Lucia:  呃body shop是一个英国牌子
Lucia: Uh, The Body Shop is a British brand.
Shure:  然后他
Shure: And then...
Shure:  他还拿了一个不到两两毛新币的
Shure: He also got a mint worth less than 2 cents.
Shure:  一个薄荷糖
Shure: A mint.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  哇以后就都给杨老板报新币
Shure: Wow, from now on, let's report everything to Jake in cents.
Lucia:  那我买了瓶饮料可以吗
Lucia: So, can I buy a drink?
Lucia:  虽然我是自己喝
Lucia: Even though it's for myself.
Lucia:  不过大概也就5毛新币吧
Lucia: It's about 5 cents, right?
Tasha:  按5毛新币
Tasha: Count it as 5 cents.
Lucia:  5毛新币
Lucia: 5 cents.
Tasha:  新币的换算比例是除五再抹个0
Tasha: The conversion rate is to divide by 5 and then round off.
Shure:  嗯除以5再抹个0
Shure: Yeah, divide by 5 and then round off.
Shure:  对他说大概是5.3
Shure: Yeah, he said it's about 5.3.
Katrina: 放我这袋里吧
Katrina: Put it in my bag.
Alice:这小的是啥啊
Alice: What is this small one?
Jake: 多少新币
Jake: How much in cents?
Jake: 10块
Jake: 10 cents.
Tasha:  十个金
Tasha: Ten gold.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure:  52块4不到1新币
Shure: 52.4 is less than 1 cent.
Tasha:  一个新币
Tasha: One cent.
Shure:  一个新币
Shure: One cent.
Shure:  不行杨老板咱先别换算呵呵
Shure: No, Jake, let's not convert it first, hehe.
Katrina: 放我这袋里吧
Katrina: Put it in my bag.
Lucia:  这放会不会有点重啊
Lucia: Will it be too heavy if I put this here?
Katrina: 他提没关系
Katrina: It's okay if he carries it.
Lucia:  哦你提啊
Lucia: Oh, you carry it?
Lucia:  那那就放了
Lucia: Then I'll put it in.
Lucia:  那我就不客气了啊哈哈
Lucia: Then I won't be polite, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈没事
Katrina: Hahaha, it's fine.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Shure:  留好小票子
Shure: Keep the receipt.
Katrina: 走吧盒马在哪呢
Katrina: Let's go, where is Hema?
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 来干正事吧
Jake: Let's get down to business.
Jake: 可以哎我看看还能录多久啊
Jake: Okay, let me see how much longer we can record.
Alice:啊一个小时
Alice: Ah, one hour.
Jake: 行那正好
Jake: That's perfect.
Jake: 正事能干一小时吗
Jake: Can we finish the business in one hour?
Jake: 买肉买肉可能用不着一小时
Jake: Buying meat shouldn't take an hour.
Katrina: 还要下去嘞
Katrina: We still need to go down.
Shure:  还要下去吗
Shure: We need to go down?
Jake: 买肉用不着一小时
Jake: Buying meat doesn't take an hour.
Jake: 再晃一晃
Jake: Let's shake it off.
Lucia:  把肉围起来观察
Lucia: Surround the meat and observe it.
Shure:  可是我们我们一会那个切肉什么的
Shure: But we, we need to cut the meat later.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  要要要
Shure: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake: 他当场切肉是吗
Jake: He cuts the meat on the spot, right?
Shure:  不是我回去处理的时候
Shure: No, I handle it when I get back.
Lucia:  你当场切肉
Lucia: You cut the meat on the spot.
Jake: 你回去处理
Jake: You handle it when you get back.
Jake: 充完电了就重来了
Jake: After recharging, we start over.
Jake: 就重来了呀
Jake: We start over, yeah.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 就不是这一波了
Jake: It's not this round.
Tasha:  哦我已经看到他了
Tasha: Oh, I already saw him.
Jake: 数据导完了
Jake: The data is transferred.
Shure:  我也看到他了
Shure: I saw him too.
Shure:  我看到了他的倒影
Shure: I saw his reflection.
Jake: 谁啊哦
Jake: Who? Oh.
Shure:  在反转世界在镜花水月中
Shure: In the reverse world, in the mirage.
Shure:  我已经看到了他
Shure: I already saw him.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Tasha:  好吧什么都不是
Tasha: Alright, it's nothing.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Shure:  要不给他给大家喂个剪头素材
Shure: Let's give him some material to cut.
Shure:  我牺牲一下
Shure: I'll sacrifice a bit.
Alice:生瓜子的味道
Alice: The smell of raw sunflower seeds.
Alice:炒瓜子啊
Alice: Roasted sunflower seeds.
Shure:  啊哇好香啊
Shure: Ah wow, it smells good.
Shure:  （歌词）无限化作深
Shure: (Lyrics) Infinitely transforming deep
Katrina: 要买烤煎烤肉的东西
Katrina: We need to buy stuff for grilling meat.
Shure:  是的走吧
Shure: Yes, let's go.
Shure:  鲜切肉脯是不是会
Shure: Will freshly sliced meat jerky...
Shure:  会跟人交流啊
Shure: Will it communicate with people?
Shure:  有有点社恐吧
Shure: A bit socially awkward, right?
其他人：你戴这眼镜干啥来了
Others: Why are you wearing those glasses?
Shure:  哟孩子你这眼镜干嘛的呀
Shure: Hey kid, what are those glasses for?
Shure:  我这矫正视力的呦喂
Shure: They're for correcting vision, oh boy.
Katrina: 哎我们那天买那个小的胡椒粉了吗
Katrina: Hey, did we buy that small pepper powder the other day?
Katrina: 好像买了哎
Katrina: I think we did.
Katrina: 这不是烤串吗
Katrina: Isn't this for skewers?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
其他人：这不用交流了
Others: No need to discuss this.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey
其他人：好吃吗
Others: Is it tasty?
Shure:  这显得我就很low
Shure: This makes me look so low.
Shure:  就没有用了你知道吗
Shure: It's useless, you know?
Jake: 签签签怎么整啊
Jake: How do we deal with the skewers?
Shure:  这显得就很没用你知道吗
Shure: It just makes me seem so useless, you know?
Jake: 那你干啥呀
Jake: So what are you gonna do?
Lucia:  这有穿好的还有签
Lucia: There are some ready-made ones here.
Jake: 哈哈哈没有签
Jake: Haha, no skewers.
Alice:这不是有穿好的吗
Alice: Aren't there ready-made ones?
Lucia:  所有的问题都解决了
Lucia: All problems are solved.
Shure:  不咱们买点鸡翅
Shure: Let's buy some chicken wings.
Shure:  我腌的鸡翅特别好吃
Shure: My marinated chicken wings are delicious.
Jake: 行整点整点
Jake: Alright, let's get some.
Tasha:  这个要拿吗
Tasha: Should we take this?
Shure:  要拿吗也拿点这个
Shure: Should we take this too?
Jake: 拿点拿点拿点
Jake: Take some, take some.
Shure:  好吧就是咱们得保证一个饿不死的
Shure: We need to make sure we won't go hungry.
Shure:  一个食食物
Shure: We need food.
Shure:  然后在在此之上
Shure: And on top of that...
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Lucia:  啊这是羊排吗
Lucia: Ah, are these lamb chops?
Shure:  我靠羊排
Shure: Wow, lamb chops.
Jake: 啥呀
Jake: What?
Shure:  然后可以憋
Shure: And then we can hold back.
Tasha:  一个新币
Tasha: One new dollar.
Tasha:  加起来一共两个新币
Tasha: Together it’s two new dollars.
Alice:10
Alice: 10
Alice:10点多
Alice: 10 plus.
Jake: 买买两个新币在新加坡就有半根串
Jake: Two new dollars in Singapore is half a skewer.
Jake: 哈哈真的是的
Jake: Haha, really.
Lucia:  10新币
Lucia: 10 new dollars.
Shure:  五十九十新币
Shure: Fifty, ninety new dollars.
Shure:  你怎么算的哈哈
Shure: How did you calculate that, haha.
Katrina: 一个新币换算成人民币是50块钱吗要
Katrina: One new dollar converted to RMB is 50 yuan, right?
Jake: 4新币 4新币
Jake: 4 dollars, 4 dollars.
Jake: 5对5.3
Jake: 5 to 5.3.
Lucia:  哈 5比5点多
Lucia: Haha, 5 to a bit over 5.
Jake: 对大概一根串
Jake: Yes, about one skewer.
Jake: 就牛肉串
Jake: Just a beef skewer.
Jake: 这种牛肉串
Jake: This kind of beef skewer.
Jake: 大概就是哎这种串
Jake: It's about this kind of skewer.
Jake: 一一新币一个哦
Jake: One, one dollar each.
Tasha:  哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake: 一新币一串
Jake: One dollar a skewer.
Jake: 对一新币一串
Jake: Yes, one dollar a skewer.
Katrina: 这也给你腌好了
Katrina: This is marinated for you.
Katrina: 怎么办呢
Katrina: What should we do?
Katrina: 这就是英雄无庸武之处啊
Katrina: This is where the hero has no use.
Shure:  不行我这不不需要不需要
Shure: No, I don't need it, don't need it.
Shure:  咱们不用这些
Shure: We don't need these.
Shure:  这这些肯定不好吃
Shure: These, these definitely don't taste good.
Katrina: 你有自己独家配方来腌吗
Katrina: Do you have your own special marinade?
Katrina: 还是怎么
Katrina: Or what?
Shure:  是的祖传十八辈了已经
Shure: Yes, it's been passed down for eighteen generations.
Katrina: 那你需要买什么调料吗
Katrina: Do you need to buy any spices?
Katrina: 那那那买这种买这种
Katrina: Then, then, buy this one, buy this one.
Jake: 哎肉买完了吗
Jake: Hey, did you finish buying the meat?
Jake: 还没开始呢
Jake: Not yet.
Katrina: 然后你拌你自己那个料
Katrina: Then you mix it with your own spices.
Jake: 瓜子
Jake: Sunflower seeds.
Lucia:  我也想知道
Lucia: I also want to know.
Lucia:  世界好癫
Lucia: The world is crazy.
Lucia:  藤椒味的瓜子
Lucia: Prickly ash flavored sunflower seeds.
Shure:  那个很好吃
Shure: That's really tasty.
Katrina: 之前成交冰淇淋呢
Katrina: Previously sold ice cream.
Shure:  巨好吃那个藤藤椒
Shure: That prickly ash is super delicious.
Katrina: 麦当劳这边出在四川限定
Katrina: McDonald's here had a Sichuan special.
Shure:  那个瓜子
Shure: Those sunflower seeds.
Lucia:  麦当劳是有什
Lucia: McDonald's has what?
Lucia:  麦当劳你有什么心事吗
Lucia: McDonald's, do you have any concerns?
Shure:  藤椒味的瓜子
Shure: Prickly ash flavored sunflower seeds.
Jake: 藤椒瓜藤椒冰淇淋
Jake: Prickly ash ice cream.
Jake: 藤椒瓜子
Jake: Prickly ash sunflower seeds.
Katrina: 之前麦当劳出过在四川限定
Katrina: McDonald's had a Sichuan special before.
Jake: 藤椒冰淇淋我靠
Jake: Sichuan pepper ice cream, oh my god.
Katrina: 就是还浇那个辣子油
Katrina: And they even pour chili oil on it.
Katrina: crazy
Katrina: Crazy.
Shure:  一斤多可以羊排
Shure: More than a pound of lamb ribs.
Katrina: 这是什么呀羊排
Katrina: What is this? Lamb ribs?
其他人：没事没事
Others: It's fine, it's fine.
Shure:  来我需要洋葱调料串
Shure: Come on, I need onion seasoning skewers.
Jake: 块那个竹签怎么整
Jake: How do we handle these bamboo skewers?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake: 竹签竹签儿
Jake: The bamboo skewers.
Shure:  呃烤的那个
Shure: Uh, the grilled ones.
Katrina: 他就直接烤肉了
Katrina: He's just grilling the meat directly.
Shure:  直接用这个
Shure: Just use this.
Shure:  然后不穿
Shure: And don't skewer it.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  咱们就烤片
Shure: We'll just grill slices.
Shure:  然后腌好
Shure: Then marinate it.
Shure:  然后烤片可以吧
Shure: And then grill slices, okay?
Jake: 行行行不要签了
Jake: Sure, sure, no skewers.
Alice:有那个夹子吗 翻面的
Alice: Do we have tongs for flipping?
Shure:  啊对好问题
Shure: Ah, good question.
Shure:  咱们再补个夹子
Shure: Let's get some tongs.
Alice:沙子跟油
Alice: Sand and oil.
Shure:  好问题啊
Shure: Good question.
Shure:  油有刷子刷子也有刷刷子
Shure: We have oil and brushes to apply it.
Alice:孜然
Alice: Cumin.
Shure:  你那天哎那谁呢
Shure: That day, hey, where's that person?
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake: 就是公寓
Jake: It's in the apartment.
Shure:  那个
Shure: That.
Jake: 在别墅里面有是吧
Jake: In the villa, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
其他人：应该有
Others: Should be.
Jake: 别说有那夹子哈
Jake: Don't say we have the tongs.
Shure:  啊OK
Shure: Ah, okay.
Alice:吃筷子也能
Alice: Chopsticks will work too.
Shure:  我为什么要拎着他呀我靠
Shure: Why am I carrying him, oh my god.
Tasha:  脚好痛啊
Tasha: My feet hurt so much.
Shure:  才想起来
Shure: Just realized.
Shure:  我还傻傻地拎着他
Shure: I was dumbly carrying him.
Shure:  这时候就应该向他问一个问题
Shure: At this moment, you should ask him a question.
Shure:  为什么我有一个车而不放进去
Shure: Why do I have a car but don't put it in?
Jake: 他花了多长时间意识到这个问题
Jake: How long did it take for him to realize this problem?
Shure:  对他花了
Shure: Yeah, he took...
Shure:  我花了多久意识到这个问题
Shure: How long did it take for me to realize this problem?
Shure:  起风了
Shure: It's getting windy.
Shure:  哎回去了
Shure: Oh, going back.
Shure:  呀
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  你们有看到鸡翅吗
Shure: Did you guys see any chicken wings?
Alice:你得去那个生肉那边买
Alice: You have to buy them over at the raw meat section.
其他人：鸡翅
Others: Chicken wings.
Lucia:  所以我上次在上海的时候惊讶的发现
Lucia: So, last time when I was in Shanghai, I was surprised to find...
Shure:  哈哈哈这一根整根参
Shure: Hahaha, this whole ginseng.
Shure:  整根鲍鱼
Shure: Whole abalone.
Shure:  俺们也可以煎三文鱼吃
Shure: We could also fry some salmon.
其他人：是有那种铁盆吗还是怎么煎啊
Others: Do we have an iron pan or how do we fry it?
Shure:  不是上面有那个栅格的那个吗
Shure: Isn't there a grill rack on top?
其他人：那就直接煎
Others: Then just fry it directly.
Shure:  对直接煎
Shure: Yeah, just fry it directly.
Alice:修
Alice: Shure.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Alice:开车走到头
Alice: Drive all the way to the end.
Alice:可能没有了
Alice: There might be none left.
Alice:可能有可能没有嗯
Alice: Maybe, maybe not, hmm.
Shure:  他说的我靠
Shure: He said, "Damn."
Shure:  你好鸡翅有了吗
Shure: Hello, do you have chicken wings?
Shure:  还鸡鸡翅鸡翅那边是吗好的
Shure: More chicken wings, over there, right? Okay.
Alice:鸡中翅
Alice: Mid-joint wings.
Shure:  鸡翅中
Shure: Mid-joint wings.
Alice:鸡中翅
Alice: Mid-joint wings.
Shure:  啊他为什么叫鸡中翅
Shure: Ah, why is it called mid-joint wings?
Shure:  可以一盒够吗
Shure: Is one box enough?
Shure:  咱们几个人
Shure: How many of us are there?
Shure:  一人两个差不多
Shure: About two per person.
Alice:13个差不多
Alice: 13 should be enough.
Shure:  啊还有一个学姐还有
Shure: Ah, and there's a senior sister, and...
Alice:你还要什么
Alice: What else do you need?
Shure:  然后就是
Shure: And then...
Alice:五花肉要吗
Alice: Do you need pork belly?
Shure:  不要我拿着排骨了
Shure: No, I got ribs.
Alice:那如果有那种一层一层的小饼也可以烤
Alice: If we have those thin pancakes, we can bake them too.
Alice:一卷
Alice: Roll them up.
Shure:  啊淄博卷饼是吧
Shure: Ah, like Zibo rolls, right?
Alice:生菜
Alice: Lettuce.
Alice:需要生菜吗
Alice: Do we need lettuce?
Shure:  可以买点
Shure: We can buy some.
Shure:  买点生菜吧
Shure: Let's buy some lettuce.
Shure:  然后卷着吃
Shure: Then we can roll it up and eat.
Alice:这是腌奥尔良的吧应该
Alice: This is marinated in Orleans style, right?
Shure:  选择相信我
Shure: Trust me.
Shure:  哈哈哈拿到了
Shure: Hahaha, got it.
其他人：拿到鸡翅了
Others: Got the chicken wings.
Lucia:  没有他是卡皮吧啦
Lucia: No, it's capybara.
Jake: 那是啥
Jake: What is that?
Lucia:  情绪稳定啊
Lucia: Emotionally stable, huh?
Lucia:  你不知道这个梗吗
Lucia: Don't you know this meme?
Jake: 不知道
Jake: No, I don't.
Lucia:  这是水豚
Lucia: It's a capybara.
Lucia:  是一种很可爱的动物
Lucia: It's a very cute animal.
Shure:  happy吧啦
Shure: Happybara.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:  然后他就是情绪特别稳定
Lucia: And it's just super emotionally stable.
Lucia:  就是即使电脑的电线断了
Lucia: Like even if a computer's wire is cut,
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:  他也能就是情绪稳定的按住
Lucia: It can stay calm and hold on.
Lucia:  直到把问题解决为止
Lucia: Until the problem is solved.
Tasha:  又买土豆
Tasha: Buy potatoes again.
其他人：不买土豆啊
Others: No potatoes.
Tasha:  买
Tasha: Buy.
Shure:  可以烤点
Shure: We can bake some.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha:  烤点
Tasha: Bake some.
Shure:  想想啊咱们是7个人
Shure: Let's see, there are seven of us.
Shure:  是7个人吃是吧
Shure: Seven people eating, right?
Tasha:  那要不要买那个烤料
Tasha: Should we buy some barbecue seasoning?
Tasha:  烤烧烤料
Tasha: Barbecue seasoning.
Shure:  是的我先算一下肉要多些
Shure: Yeah, I'll first calculate how much meat we need.
Shure:  这么多鸡蛋
Shure: So many eggs.
Lucia:  这薇薇要做甜点要用
Lucia: Tasha needs them for making desserts.
Shure:  啊那一会借我两个
Tasha:  不借哈哈哈哈
Alice:洋葱
Shure:  要要腌的话会
Tasha:  要腌
Tasha:  东西要用嗯
Lucia:  哦OK
Lucia:  我以为要往上面裹汁嘞
Alice:洋葱
Shure:  对洋葱
Shure:  我先算算一下肉的肉的量
Alice:在那呢
Alice:但是他你要不
Alice:买那个洋葱吧
Shure:  我要紫皮洋葱
Shure:  紫皮洋葱
Jake: 这个很紫啊
Jake: 这边啊
Alice:这个有机的
Alice:这个普通的
Alice: This is pretty average.
Tasha:  没关系我们就吃贵的
Tasha: It's okay, we'll just get the expensive one.
Lucia:  要大的还是小的
Lucia: Do you want the big one or the small one?
Jake: 有机多少钱
Jake: How much is the organic one?
Tasha:  我觉得要小的比较
Tasha: I think the smaller one is better.
Shure:  organic
Shure: Organic.
Tasha:  呃要三个小的比较好
Tasha: Uh, getting three small ones is better.
Tasha:  这样子的话就不会浪费
Tasha: That way, we won't waste any.
Lucia:  400克5块9 这个是那个类
Lucia: 400 grams for 5.9. This is that kind.
Jake: 这多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Lucia:  如果我没看错
Lucia: If I didn't read it wrong.
Shure:  一新币这个
Shure: It's one dollar.
Jake: 这多少钱半新币
Jake: How much is it? Half a dollar?
Shure:  这多少
Shure: How much is this?
Shure:  4块3 我们差别
Shure: 4.3. We're different.
Jake: 没差别
Jake: No difference.
Alice:1不到1
Alice: Less than 1.
Jake: 那没差别
Jake: Then no difference.
Jake: 有机
Jake: Organic.
Tasha:  没差别
Tasha: No difference.
Jake: 哈哈啊就差一块钱
Jake: Haha, just one dollar short.
Shure:  啊但是这个比那个轻 100克
Shure: Ah, but this one is 100 grams lighter than that one.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  够了这些
Shure: That's enough.
Shure:  然后肉的话一斤一斤半
Shure: And for the meat, about one to one and a half pounds.
Alice:需要土豆什么吗
Alice: Do we need potatoes or something?
Alice:土豆生菜
Alice: Potatoes and lettuce.
Shure:  一斤半土豆拿了
Shure: We got one and a half pounds of potatoes.
Shure:  然后底下那些串
Shure: And then those skewers.
Alice:生菜
Alice: Lettuce.
Shure:  然后也也有肉是不
Shure: And there's also meat, right?
Shure:  这是多少斤
Shure: How many pounds is this?
Shure:  300克才 300克量
Shure: Only 300 grams, 300 grams.
Alice:生菜需要吗
Alice: Do we need lettuce?
Shure:  需要拿点生菜
Shure: We need to get some lettuce.
Alice:生菜在那呢
Alice: The lettuce is over there.
Shure:  我不太爱吃那个口蘑
Shure: I don't really like button mushrooms.
Shure:  母子平安还是母女平安
Shure: Mother and child are safe or mother and daughter are safe?
Jake: 我们回去之后
Jake: After we get back,
Jake: 呃哪一个小时用来给我传数据了
Jake: Um, which hour will you use to send me the data?
Shure:  立即传
Shure: I'll send it immediately.
Lucia:  刚回去的那个小时吧
Lucia: How about the hour right after we get back?
Jake: 立即传啊
Jake: Send it immediately.
Shure:  对然后因为我们要处理这些的
Shure: Yeah, because we need to handle these.
Shure:  就也要也要拍一下了是吧
Shure: So we also need to film a bit, right?
Jake: OK那对对是的
Jake: OK, yeah, that's right.
Jake: 所以回去之后先放冰箱就给我传是吗
Jake: So after we get back, put it in the fridge and then send it to me, right?
Jake: 要放冰箱吗
Jake: Does it need to go in the fridge?
Shure:  对也其实也
Shure: Yes, actually, also...
Alice:要的要的
Alice: Yes, it does.
Lucia:  放冰箱要拍吗
Lucia: Do we need to film it going into the fridge?
Shure:  没那么那啥
Shure: Not really.
Jake: 要拍放一下吧放一下吧
Jake: Just film it a bit, just a bit.
Alice:放一下吧
Alice: Just a bit.
Lucia:  那就放啊
Lucia: Then just put it in.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Alice:冷藏一下
Alice: Refrigerate it for a bit.
Jake: 放下等着然后开始切是吧
Jake: Put it in, wait, and then start cutting, right?
Shure:  够吗
Shure: Is that enough?
其他人：你们几个吃差不多够了
Others: For you guys, it's probably enough.
Shure:  咱们7个人吧不是
Shure: There are seven of us, right?
其他人：有主食吗
Others: Do we have any main dishes?
Shure:  没有主食
Shure: No main dishes.
其他人：那就不吃主食
Others: Then we won't have any main dishes.
Shure:  对不吃主食
Shure: Yeah, no main dishes.
Lucia:  主食土土土豆
Lucia: Main dish, potatoes.
其他人：烤面包片也可以
Others: Toast would work too.
Jake: 有有土豆
Jake: We have potatoes.
Lucia:  那土豆也算是一种主食
Lucia: Well, potatoes are kind of a main dish.
Lucia:  因为主要主要成分是淀粉对吧
Lucia: Because their main component is starch, right?
Alice:土豆三个够吗
Alice: Are three potatoes enough?
Lucia:  强词夺理
Lucia: Justifying nonsense.
Shure:  可以烤点面包片
Shure: We could toast some bread.
Shure:  对来来点面包片吧
Shure: Yeah, let's toast some bread.
其他人：对我吃烧烤就想吃面包片
Others: Yeah, I like having toast with barbecue.
Shure:  你媳妇呢
Shure: Where's your wife?
Shure:  再再来两个
Shure: Let's have two more.
Lucia:  那今天得把它吃掉
Lucia: We should finish it today.
Shure:  这个
Shure: This...
Lucia:  不然容易坏
Lucia: Or it'll go bad.
Katrina: 啊好
Katrina: Ah, okay.
Lucia:  然后我们再补充一点水果
Lucia: Then we can add some fruits.
Shure:  好够了肯定够了
Shure: Alright, that's enough, definitely enough.
Katrina: 草莓呢也得吃
Katrina: We need to eat the strawberries too.
Alice:草莓有一盒那个要干嘛
Alice: We have a box of strawberries, what are we going to do with them?
Alice:做做做
Alice: Make... make...
Shure:  然后调料
Shure: And the seasoning.
Katrina: 北冰洋配烤肉
Katrina: Arctic Ocean soda with barbecue.
Shure:  来一箱什么
Shure: A box of what?
Shure:  来一打
Shure: A dozen?
Katrina: 北冰洋配烤肉
Katrina: Arctic Ocean soda with barbecue.
Shure:  不应该啤酒配烤肉吗
Shure: Shouldn't it be beer with barbecue?
Katrina: no北冰洋配烤肉
Katrina: No, Arctic Ocean soda with barbecue.
Katrina: 我们小孩吃
Katrina: It's what kids drink.
Shure:  还小孩呢
Shure: Kids, huh?
Shure:  到法定结
Shure: You're at the legal age...
Shure:  婚年龄了吧
Shure: for marriage, right?
Shure:  我还没到呢
Shure: I'm not there yet.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Shure:  我那天还试了一下
Shure: I even tried the other day.
Katrina: 你是去民政局了
Katrina: You went to the civil affairs bureau?
Shure:  不我是民政局预约后来不行
Shure: No, I made an appointment at the Civil Affairs Bureau, but it didn't work out.
Katrina: 哎呀我去拿水果去
Katrina: Oh, I'll go get some fruit.
Shure:  然后去买调料
Shure: Then I'll go buy the seasoning.
Shure:  调料在那
Shure: The seasoning is over there.
Shure:  米面粮油对
Shure: Rice, flour, grain, and oil, right.
Shure:  有大瓶的
Shure: There's a big bottle.
Shure:  全是咱们用不了这么多
Shure: It's too much for us to use.
Shure:  怎么办呢
Shure: What should we do?
Lucia:  烤味呃
Lucia: BBQ flavor, uh...
Lucia:  烧烤汁吗
Lucia: BBQ sauce?
Shure:  不是需要料酒
Shure: No, we need cooking wine.
Alice:放料酒吗
Alice: Do we add cooking wine?
Shure:  需要
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  不然的话技师会很行
Shure: Otherwise, it won't be good.
Alice:洋葱
Alice: Onions.
Shure:  也不行得需要料酒
Shure: No, we need cooking wine.
Lucia:  如果说
Lucia: What if...
Shure:  九块九六块九的
Shure: 9.9 or 6.9.
Shure:  哎一新币两新币
Shure: Oh, one yuan or two yuan.
Shure:  这太大了这也
Shure: This is too big, it'll go to waste.
Shure:  吃不了就浪费了
Shure: We can't eat it all, it'll be wasted.
Lucia:  耗油
Lucia: Oyster sauce.
Shure:  有小的吗
Shure: Is there a smaller one?
Shure:  你好这些有小的吗
Shure: Hello, do you have a smaller one?
Shure:  啊不好意思不好意思不好意思
Shure: Ah, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Alice:这种的多少钱你看
Alice: How much is this kind? Look.
Alice:蚝油你要用来腌啥
Alice: What are you marinating with the oyster sauce?
Shure:  也是腌肉
Shure: Also marinating meat.
Alice:白糖我没有白糖
Alice: I don't have any white sugar.
Shure:  你说白糖还要要一瓶
Shure: You said we also need a bottle of white sugar.
Shure:  一定要一瓶百事可乐
Shure: We definitely need a bottle of Pepsi.
Shure:  因为可口没有那么甜
Shure: Because Coke isn't as sweet.
Shure:  哎那有那有蚝油啊
Shure: Oh, there it is, there's the oyster sauce.
Alice:要更贵
Alice: It'll be more expensive.
Lucia:  但是它其实更贵
Lucia: But it's actually more expensive.
Shure:  我们是以着不浪费的原则
Shure: We're trying to avoid waste.
Shure:  还是以更贵的原则
Shure: Or should we go for the more expensive one?
Lucia:  嗯看你是指资源还是金钱的浪费了
Lucia: Hmm, depends if you mean wasting resources or money.
Lucia:  哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure:  我是指资源
Shure: I mean resources.
Alice:我们过几天会有什么饭需要做吗
Alice: Do we have any meals that need to be cooked in the next few days?
Shure:  不会
Shure: No.
Lucia:  做饭感觉主要只是为了采集一下
Lucia: Cooking mainly feels like just for collecting stuff.
Shure:  而而且就这玩意
Shure: And this thing...
Lucia:  人类活动而已
Lucia: It's just a human activity.
Shure:  这玩意够用一个月的了都
Shure: This thing is enough for a month.
Alice:耗油很省的
Shure:  对啊来来这个吧来这个
Shure: Yeah, let's go with this one, this one.
Shure:  然后别别浪费粮食
Shure: And don't waste food.
Shure:  浪费粮食
Shure: Don't waste food.
Alice:蘸料
Alice: Dipping sauce.
Shure:  这都是腌咸的
Shure: These are all salted.
Shure:  就不用蘸料了
Shure: No need for dipping sauce.
Alice:不用摘啊
Alice: No need to dip?
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Alice:那孜然呢
Alice: What about cumin?
Shure:  孜然那些调料是要用的
Shure: Cumin and those seasonings are needed.
Shure:  再找一下这边
Shure: Let's look around here.
Alice:六婆直接六婆吧
Alice: Liupo, just use Liupo.
Shure:  六婆是什么
Alice:六婆辣椒面
Alice: Liupo chili powder.
Shure:  我靠没听过这个
Shure: Damn, I've never heard of that.
Alice:六婆这么有名的蘸料
Alice: Liupo is such a famous dipping sauce.
Shure:  真没清过
Shure: Really never heard of it.
Shure:  盐咱们有是吧
Shure: We have salt, right?
Alice:有
Alice: Yes.
Alice:糖也有
Alice: We have sugar too.
Shure: 芝麻
Shure: Sesame.
Jake: 这个多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me see.
其他人：可以
Others: Okay.
Katrina: 笑什么
Katrina: Why are you laughing?
Lucia:  是是那天那个1,600块钱的帝王蟹吗
Lucia: Is it that 1,600 RMB king crab from that day?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈不是
Jake: Hahaha, no.
Lucia:  还是啥
Lucia: Or what?
Shure:  哎波龙才469啊
Shure: Hey, the lobster is only 469.
Shure:  换算除5的话不到100新币
Shure: Converting to SGD, it's less than 100.
Shure:  90都不到
Shure: Not even 90.
Jake: 波龙还是波龙不应该这么贵
Jake: Lobster, lobsters shouldn't be this expensive.
Shure:  哎茴茴香和孜然是一个东西吗
Shure: Hey, are fennel and cumin the same thing?
Shure:  不是吧
Shure: I don't think so.
Shure:  茴香和孜然是一个东西吗
Shure: Are fennel and cumin the same thing?
Jake: 还缺什么呀
Jake: What else are we missing?
Shure:  还缺孜然
Shure: We're still missing cumin.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Jake: 明早让他们做个早饭
Jake: Let's have them make breakfast in the morning.
Jake: 明早你们做个早饭吧
Jake: You guys make breakfast tomorrow morning.
Alice:面包还没买呢
Alice: We haven't bought the bread yet.
Alice:生菜有但是不知道够不够
Alice: We have lettuce, but I'm not sure if it's enough.
Jake: 就就在屋里待着了
Jake: Just stay inside.
Jake: 跳跳舞什么的
Jake: Dance or something.
Jake: 然后如果快递到了就整一整
Jake: And if the delivery arrives, deal with it.
其他人：晚上有点事
Others: There's something going on tonight.
其他人：拜拜
Others: Bye-bye.
Shure:  哪里有
Shure: Where?
Jake: 周日见周日来是吧
Jake: See you on Sunday, you're coming on Sunday, right?
Shure:  拜拜哦
Shure: Bye-bye.
Jake: 拜拜
Jake: Bye-bye.
Shure:  那是咱们是6个人啊
Shure: So it's just the six of us?
Jake: 怎么
Jake: What?
Shure:  那没事吃不了
Shure: That's fine, we can't finish it.
Shure:  周日再弄吧
Shure: Let's do it on Sunday.
Jake: 对可以好
Jake: Yeah, that's good.
Shure:  没事了没事
Shure: It's fine, no worries.
其他人：OK没事了
Others: OK, no worries.
Jake: 拜拜
Jake: Bye-bye.
Katrina: 拜拜
Katrina: Bye-bye.
Shure:  哇你还买冰淇淋了
Shure: Wow, you even bought ice cream.
Katrina: 偷偷的夹带私货哈哈
Katrina: Sneaking in some goodies, haha.
Shure:  孜然哥我们还需要孜然
Shure: Cumin guy, we still need cumin.
Shure:  这是孜然粉
Shure: This is cumin powder.
Shure:  不是孜然
Shure: Not cumin seeds.
Katrina: 孜然和孜然粉有什么区别
Katrina: What's the difference between cumin and cumin powder?
Alice:我们还有白胡椒
Alice: We also have white pepper.
Katrina: 孜然和孜然粉有什么区别
Katrina: What's the difference between cumin and cumin powder?
Shure:  粒儿的和粉它其实不太一样
Shure: The seeds and powder are actually quite different.
Alice:这是啥辣椒粉辣椒面
Alice: What is this, chili powder or chili flakes?
Katrina: 买面包了吗
Katrina: Did you buy bread?
Katrina: 没有是吧
Katrina: No, right?
Alice:还没买面包呢
Alice: We haven't bought the bread yet.
Shure:  行那再买点面面包
Shure: Okay, let's buy some more bread.
Katrina: 买个面包个番茄酱
Katrina: Get some bread and ketchup.
Shure:  然后剩下的没有了就外卖一下吧
Shure: And if there's nothing left, we can order takeout.
Katrina: OK走吧
Katrina: Okay, let's go.
Katrina: 面包
Katrina: Bread.
Katrina: 面包在哪
Katrina: Where's the bread?
Katrina: 是不是在那方向
Katrina: Is it in that direction?
Shure:  有上次有一个什么烘焙的那地方
Shure: Last time, there was a bakery in that place.
Katrina: 然后我们最大的花销就是吃
Katrina: Our biggest expense is food.
Lucia:  这里没有
Lucia: It's not here.
Lucia:  那天那个帝王蟹耶
Lucia: That day, there was king crab.
Shure:  住更贵一点
Shure: Living costs a bit more.
Jake: 关联建立失败
Jake: Connection failed.
Katrina: 哎这是吃饭点
Katrina: Hey, it's meal time.
Katrina: 人家烘焙区呢
Katrina: Where's the bakery?
Katrina: 上次来的盒马没有这种店哎
Katrina: Last time at Hema, there wasn't such a store.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Lucia:  尝试一下建立别的关联
Lucia: Try establishing another connection.
Lucia:  那天还看到什么了
Lucia: What else did we see that day?
Shure:  有小弟弟啊
Shure: There was a little brother.
Shure:  不对
Shure: No, that's not right.
Shure:  应该算
Shure: Maybe it counts.
Shure:  大家侄子对侄子
Shure: Everyone's nephew, right?
Shure:  其实
Shure: Actually.
Jake: 咋的
Jake: What's up?
Shure:  其实我们还可以弄点什么花蛤啥的
Shure: Actually, we can get some clams or something.
Shure:  烤一下哦
Shure: And grill them.
Shure:  最重要的碳
Shure: Most importantly, charcoal.
Shure:  对一会回去的路上咱们先把碳点着
Shure: Yeah, on the way back, let's light the charcoal first.
Shure:  然后分两
Shure: Then split it.
Katrina: 有点碳的东西吗
Katrina: Do we have any charcoal stuff?
Shure:  火火机咱们有吗
Shure: Do we have a lighter?
Alice:火枪
Alice: A torch.
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Alice:一般卖碳的地方是不是会有那个啊
Alice: Usually, places selling charcoal have it, right?
Katrina: 刷油的刷子和油有吗
Katrina: Do we have a brush for oil and the oil itself?
Shure:  啊刷子好像
Shure: Ah, we might have a brush.
Alice:我们
Alice: We.
Alice:我们用纸箱动的话可以用它引火
Alice: If we move the cardboard, we can use it to start the fire.
Alice:只要有个打火机就行了
Alice: We just need a lighter.
Shure:  也可以
Shure: That works too.
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure:  刚刚那会好像你们你们先往那边走
Shure: It seems like you guys should head that way first.
Shure:  你好咱这有卖碳的吗
Shure: Hi, do you sell charcoal here?
其他人：没有
Others: No.
Shure:  没有是吗好的
Shure: No? Okay, got it.